[Musique]
nous sommes ici en entrevue avec deux
champions il s'agit de catherine dumas
bonjour bonjour
et puis et alexandre guedjali d eric gay
comme les champions de ski et vous êtes
un champion aussi donc bienvenu merci
d'avoir accepté des devenez à nos
studios ici à radio canada vous êtes
champions parce que vous savez
participer compétitionner dans le cadre
des solins pyatt canadiennes des métiers
et des technologies
en photographie donc vous savez gagner
tous les deux une médaille d'or à 1
photographie justement postsecondaire
niveau postsecondaire un niveau
secondaire
donc comment vous vous sentez quelles
sont vos premières impressions avec vos
bons médaille
on est vraiment très heureux très fier
aussi
exactement c'est une belle expérience
moi je suis vraiment content de l'avoir
gagné parce que sans preuve à tout ce
que vous savez aussi gagné catherine une
autre médaille c'est la médaille du prix
excellence québec qui est donné par les
volets québécois des skills compétences
canada dans quelles compétences québec
qui vous donne une médaille pour être la
meilleure de la région donc là de la
province québécoise
donc comment vous sentez pas la personne
l'épaule c'est quoi qui comment on gagne
ses deux médailles offertes en fait
c'est tous métiers confondus
il y avait un calcul qui était fait
entre la médaille d'or et la médaille
d'argent il y avait un calcul puis
ensuite ce soit je gagne donc le plus
haut score au québec
c'était une belle surprise je ne
m'attendais pas nécessairement à ça donc
en plus cette année pour la première
année compétences québec remettait aussi
une bourse donc double surprise est
vraiment un bon moment
je très contente vous disiez tout à
l'heure que vous savez l'impression que
enfin il y avait des gens qui vous avait
dit que vous réussirez pas à
photographier comment vous s'est rendu à
la photographie c'est quoi votre
cheminement pour vous rendre là j'ai
depuis tout petit je fais de la photo
eh ben je voulais vraiment pas un
courant photographie pour tours
justement acquérir les compétences de
plus pourrait perfectionner pour faire
en faire mon métier comme jeudi soir les
gens qui m'ont dit que ça marcherait
porte la photo si j'avais l'argent je
serai pas là dedans je pense j'essaie de
prouver puisque ça dans le fond avec
l'école ils m'ont orienté vraiment pour
que pour m'aider j'ai eu des
conseillères d'orientation qui m'ont
aidé vraiment pour m'orienter pour
m'aider à y aller à faire le coc aller
chercher le dmp elles m'ont vraiment
conseillé quand parfait pour m'aider
pour rechercher fne mode est que réponde
avec mon diplôme de tout soldat dans sa
tâche et ont vraiment tout donné
littbarski seule gérée par ici on va
expliquer quand même seconde et hop et
parce que les gens qui nous qui nous
regardent
non probablement pas toutes les
informations parce qu'il ya deux mondes
qui nous écoutent à l'étranger donc
qu'est-ce qui est un des meilleurs pour
nous l'expliquer mais un dp souvent
c'est ma force et en compromettant avec
un dlc qui a un diplôme d'études
collégiales dec diplôme d'études
professionnelles
c'est vraiment un métier professionnel
que dans le fond dans ce qu au loto
rappaz les autres compétences
en attendant les lits comme c'est
obligatoire quand au calme et au cégep
l'oeuvre des cours de base anglais
français philosophale on n'a pas ce nom
qu'on s'oriente vraiment sur le mythe 6
attrait pour pouvoir travailler pour se
perfectionner pour le métier choisi la
photographie depuis longtemps c'est
devenu quelque chose de professionnel
donc mais maintenant vous pouvez y
travailler avec à travailler dans votre
cas catherine je sais que vous étiez
dans un autre milieu complètement et
puis qui vous savez choisi de suivre
vraiment vos rêves aussi d'une certaine
manière donc voir les nous un petit peu
de votre parcours en photographie
l'enfant ce que vous dites c'est vrai
c'était un rêve aussi d'étudier dans un
domaine créatif quelque chose
d'artistique
je dérange d'acheter dans le domaine
médical donc complètement complètement
oppose depuis mais il y avait quand même
peut-être des quelques trucs artistique
on pouvait retrouver mais il manquait
toujours cette ce côté créatif l'appui
la photo ça venait juste rejoindre tout
ça à faire donc oui je réalise un rêve
en ce moment d'étudier en photo puis
avec les olympiades a juste confirmé
qu'on était au bon endroit au bon moment
comment vous voyez comment vous vous
envisagez en fait votre avenir
professionnel à court et à long terme
comment qu'est-ce que vous perdez
l'avenir enfin il ya plusieurs gens qui
me de ventes c'est justement à cause de
marie orientation carrière pour
l'instant je pense beaucoup photo on
baigne là-dedans puis j'adore en ce
moment qu'est ce que je vis donc je
pouvais vous parlez de photo en faisant
que je vois peut-être au niveau plus
commerciales publicitaires
j'aime aussi beaucoup le portrait
corporatif donc pour l'instant c'est ce
que je vise
une bo photographie et 40 des photos ou
ses méfaits moi j'avais vraiment pas de
la photo de l'événement de show les
groupes de musique c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui m'allume juste
l'énergique quand on voit photographier
un show l'énergie que tout à fait être
l'énergie en plus puis ça fait penser un
peu j'ai commencé la photo animalière
que photographe il est à présent cela il
leur apporte dans un obama c'est pour
moi la faute aux dossards sont en place
merci c'est facile de garder sa vie
là-dedans enfin je me vois vraiment dans
la photo de chaud parce que je retrouve
juste avant les événements d'animal il
vraiment tout ces jeux du chat que j'ai
fait des choses des des geeks haute
bâtisse et ils font pas salon a sauté
avec fauteuils l'achète à ce moment je
m' a capté le moment voici où ça se
passe ouais j'aime aussi le volet
artistique mais j'aime aussi le volet
que votre soit yannick soit comme lol ce
moment là c'est après cet arrêt chivuta
regard des photos des fichiers recevoir
qui régissent
ça s'est passé que quelques secondes
même pendant la prise de vue tu ne l'a
même pas vu
puis toi tu t'en 17 heures comptant le
louvre en torchis puis la photo qui vous
a fait gagner cette série enfin vous
travaillez vous faites comme des
poussières cette table si je comprends
bien assez tôt et une olympiade là mais
la photo qui vous ça ou les photos qui
vous ont fait gagner ce qu'on peut
l'aider crise que ça rende à celle d'un
type des photographies particulier pour
moi
d'après moi les photos qui m'ont fait
gragnic m'ont donné beaucoup de points
si mes photos artistiques
j'ai vraiment été fort l'adage savait
qu'il y avait des faiblesses on a des
places
non je me suis déjà fait c'est comme
faux dans les photos artistiques rocha
marché c'était une photo d'enfant c'est
un objet une star qu'on avait des
troubles nommage été mis sur l'iphone
doive com
ainsi marc béton de la vgc mais là
dessus j'ai donné en noir et blanc
j'ai été utilisé en effet de zone pour
qu ils aillent vraiment la corde pour
nous la photo qui est la salle et robben
devant leur vol car c'est parfait parce
que c'est ça on vous donne des défis
pour cette compétition là pour cette
olympiade l'a donc dans votre coeur
qu'aux membres de créer sur la photo qui
vous dont vous êtes le plus fier dans
cette compétition particulier ce1
d'enfants russes mystérieux de voler
vous sauver 40 et évaluer les deux il y
avait quelques différences entre le
niveau secondaire postsecondaire au
niveau par exemple moi j'avais un
portrait à faire lui c'était un peu
comme un produit ou un comme on appelle
ça un one stop shop c'est une table
lumineuse qu'on photographie moss en
bouteille d'eau au début je pensais sac
à dos puisque des personnes merkado ça
on n'avait pas l'équipement de salles
romanes nécessaire pour bien le travail
sinon c'était vraiment quand même si
müller des choses pareilles donc qu'il y
avait des objets mystère comme il est
mentionné pour le trombone il y avait
des jeux je veux aussi que nous a donné
des serpents jupe on avait des briards
juste des petits sachets de brillants
avec serait fallait trouver une façon
artistique de se démarquer aussi de
faire une photo le plus original
possible dans les lieux de la
compétition peut le lui la compétition
c'est un stand d'exposition béton et y
avait un petit peu lumière naturelle
nous on les photographes on recherche
toujours un coin de lumière offerte
puis sinon c'est ça il y avait ensuite
dit volée photo ça aux retouches dont
colette fort techniquement pour avoir
une bonne photo parce qu'on a retouché
passé l'a ensuite il y avait aussi un
triptyque que c'était trois photos qu'on
allait faire qui avait une thématique
qui les trois photos des restes rejoint
n'avait cousty l'aspect peut-être la
coloration des choses comme ça puis il y
avait aussi
s'il y avait mon portrait il y avait un
montage aussi photo sha donc les deux on
avait un montage différent faire mais
c'était vraiment des éléments qu'on
allait remettre ensemble aussi avec le
logiciel puis votre préféré pas vraiment
été mon portrait que c'est un moment que
j'ai adoré ça super bien et n'était
monté ma lumière tout tout à coup les la
mode elle c'était quelqu'un qu'on allait
voir à cette journée là quelques minutes
elle apparaît voir varet pas prévoir il
fallait faire des choix sur son
habillement et tout puis j'ai tellement
aimé ce moment là je pense encore que
c'est vraiment un bon moment
ouais je félicite vraiment félicitations
vous êtes des champions et puis on vous
souhaite beaucoup de chance pour
l'avenir parce que dans le fond ce que
je vois c'est beaucoup de passion et je
pense qu'avec la passion on peut aller
très très loin
merci beaucoup catherine d'humains alex
tanguay s'est beaucoup donc j'espère
qu'ils allaient continuer demain vous
êtes bien parti
[Musique]